hey there and welcome to this pro flows
quick tip on how to create
light wrap that actually works well for
you so if you don't have a third-party
plug-in to do light wrapping here's the
way you can do it manually
and this approach is a little bit more
superior in
my opinion to others that exist out
there where you use
effects like setmat and i teach the
other approach
and beyond the parallax effect this is a
little bit better approach that i've
learned since then what's great about
this approach is that you can use this
on any size
images so and some other approaches not
to dive too deeply in them you have to
have images
or pre-comps that are set to your
composition side and you have to
pre-comp and do some
extra steps this one's a lot easier so i
have a beach
scene here you can see it's just a photo
and you can use this for cg renderers or
whatever this is a great technique to
really blend
images together okay so i've got a beach
lounger here i love the beach
and here is our 3d render or it could be
a photograph whatever
we want to blend it in a little bit
better to the background here so the
first i'm going to do is i'm going to
drop
the scale of this down just
something like that so there it looks
okay but it doesn't quite look like it
blends
perfectly into the background and to do
that
we need to do light wrapping this
approach works for any size
imagery or cg renders so what we're
going to do is we're going to select our
first
our top image that has to be the light
wrap and we're going to go to channel
and we're going to go to channel and
we're going to say set
channels and we're going to set each of
these channels
red to our background green
to our background and blue to our
background so there we go so now the
image
just blends into the background just
like so next we're going to apply effect
blur and sharpen gaussian blur
and for this a lot of times i like to
turn repeat edge pixels on just
to be safe i'm going to crank this way
up to something like
50. so it's nice and blurry here this
number will depend on the size of the
imagery that you're working with
so it's all about trial and error here
and we can always come back
and adjust this at any time next we're
going to go to
channel and we're going to invert and
we're going to actually invert
the alpha channel so we're going to go
all the way down to the bottom here
select invert the alpha channel
looks a little bit funky but the next
thing i'm going to do is we're going to
go back into channel
and we're going to go to cc composite
this is a very
powerful plugin that is often
overlooked we're going to set this to
stencil alpha
and so now we're starting to see here
we've got our our light wrapping
happening if i turn off the background
you can really see what's going on right
there okay so last thing we need to do
now is just go back to
cc composite again and we can actually
duplicate this effect or we can just add
a new one
set it to screen
and untick rgb only and there we go
there is our beautiful light wrap you
can adjust the
gaussian blur settings at any point here
to get the light wrap to really change
in its appearance so here we're set to
50.
if i drop this to 25 you're gonna see
it's a much softer
light wrap here so if i go down here and
i just turn the effects off
i want you to look to the edge of this
chair no effects
with effects of light wrapping one other
quick thing i want to point out is
besides just playing around with the
actual blur level and getting a softer
or harsher
edge wrap light wrap you can also play
around with the last composite setting
of screen you can change this to
something like
lighten it's just gonna be a little bit
more subtle you can also
play around with different transfer
modes like multiply add overlay
things like that you're gonna get
completely different types of light
wraps
by playing around with that that is how
you quickly
build a light ramp that works
inside of after effects